um but before we get right into the
topic we have new people exactly emily
emily
executives at this ad agency in hamburg
hold a big meeting each monday
janina levy from hamburg is managing
director of the firm
it's germany's oldest ad agency founded
in 1876 by william wilkins
mr wilkins realized early on the
potential in advertising the products of
the merchants based here
the ad agency continues to do that to
this day
it's changed hand several times and is
now called fcb but it's remained true to
hamburg
so has its biggest client skin care
company biozdorf the agency has made ads
for the firm for over a
century known brand nivea got a major
makeover in 1925 when the color of its
tube changed from yellow to blue
i think this shade of blue automatically
gives it a bit of hanseatic flair
the advertising director at the time
used to be a ship's captain
so naturally blue had played a big role
in his
that's life medrine naturally
isn't she cute
this commercial from 1957 targeted
british buyers can't believe that one
day it may look like this yes it may but
it does in typically hanseatic style the
ads were rather reserved
like the nivea brand the fcb agency has
also gone global today it belongs to an
american holding company and employs
people from 23 different nations
an international approach is vital when
it comes to marketing products around
the world
what do the store signs or packaging
look like
it starts off with design and with humor
too it's about how to tell stories how
people talk to one another so that flows
into the concept
american mark warfield moved to hamburg
from new york four years ago
it took him a while to get used to the
northern german ways
people here tend not to mince their
words yet clients are often hesitant to
take risks
but he and his family aren't complaining
um
well i think i mean i think they
complain that the in the winter there's
only a couple hours of sunlight we're
not quite used to that
but
no in some ways it's the opposite my one
son had never complained about new york
before and then when we came back for a
vacation he told me that brooklyn smells
then they're off to another meeting
fcb is just one of close to 6 000 ad
agencies in hamburg
the city on the elbe numbers among the
world's most creative hot spots